ساعود رولكس بملايين الدولارات ففي عام
2017 بعد ساعه ويدن باكثر من 15 مليون
دولار لكن ما سر ارتفاع اسعار اسعارها
السر عند الالماني والزورف الذي كان
موهوبا بتصاميمه رائعه وترويج لها بذكاء
غير ان اغلب مكوناتها تجمع يدويا داخل
سويسرا التي تشتهر بارتفاع تكلفه الايدي
العامله وهناك سبب اخر لارتفاع سعر رولكس
وهو يستخدمه مواد باهضه الثمن مثل الذهب
الابيض في تصنيع الموانئ الساعه وتزويد
محرك الساعه باحجار كريمه وصناعه الارقام
من البلاطين واستخدام نوع فؤاد مقاوم
للصداع والسبب الاخير للارتفاع سعرها
واحتفظها بقيمتها عند اعاده البيع ورغم كل
ذلك روليكس لا تعتبر شركه هادفه للربح بل
تصنف نفسها على انها مؤسسه خيريه
[موسيقى]